now i
i know that this is going to be
a shock
to a lot of you and
i think it's something that i i just
need to say
i'm not cisgender
[Applause]
[Music]
glad to have that off my chest
so
this video is going to be something uh
quite a bit different
i've been thinking for a little while
about talking about the experience of
coming out on youtube
especially after having already built a
bit of a platform before i did so
except it's something that i've talked
about before in various capacities that
i probably will talk about again you
know if anybody
wants to ask me in detail i can always
answer those questions but i kind of
wanted to
have a deeper look a more extensive look
because you know shock of shocks
trans people aren't a monolith
so
whatever my experience was
is not necessarily representative of
what the experience of other people is
so
i took a shot in the dark
reached out to
nearly every trans creator i could think
of who had started their channel prior
to being out i sent inquiries to some
some big names expecting honestly for
nobody to get back to me and for the
entire project to just collapse under
the weight of ah
nobody wants to do it
well that didn't happen
so you are going to be hearing
from four different trans creators
james stephanie sterling of the gym
inquisition
may leads of nick spheres
jxe of
j
xe
and jesse earle aka jesse gender
now out of these four jesse is slightly
the odd one out because though it is
technically true she started her channel
and began uploading videos prior to
coming out she wasn't public facing and
the channel was pretty small by the time
she did come out but i still thought
that she could lend a good perspective
to the proceedings so this will be the
last you're going to hear from me until
the very end of the video other than to
point one thing out i'm also doing
something a little extra with this one
because i don't generally do this but
there is going to be a patreon exclusive
material here because
this video
in its first assembly was literally
twice as long
so i'm going to be offering up to my
patreon supporters
the full
uncut videos for each of these four
interviews and those will be available
to patrons at any tier and if that
sounds interesting to you and you're not
already a patron
there's the thing hopefully something
fun i don't normally do videos that
accommodate this kind of extra material
but that's enough stalling for me
let's talk about
coming out on youtube
hi i'm jay i make videos about media
on
any kind of media really i'm james
stephanie sterling um
otherwise known as jim sterling that's
my my work name i guess
uh i am a video game industry critic
my name is mei leitz i'm a youtuber
focusing on
horror movies uh and
[Music]
my i guess kind of the macabre side of
life i'm jesse gender i'm a youtuber
that likes to use nerdums geekdoms and
mostly star trek because star trek is
the best thing to talk about lgbtq and
specifically transgender issues but also
some social and political issues as well
i produce videos primarily the gym
inquisition which is on mundanes and
takes something from the game industry
and talks about it
usually very critical because there's a
lot of horrible stuff that goes on in
the game industry so i talk about
industry abuse i talk about monetization
in the game industry the way they
overstep with them you're basically just
having a pot when i say any kind of
media anything goes it can be a real
estate agent's tour of a house that's
that's the kind of broad definition
we're talking about here my main thesis
statement is i try to lead people into
the worst darkness they can imagine
and then walk them out of it so they
know never to go there again and over
time i've introduced more and more
anti-capitalist concepts into it
to try and figure out like how we use
our media to understand our everyday
lives in our everyday world and i tend
to like to make fun of bad things while
also reaching into the actual
analytical side of what makes them bad
also i choked slam people so
those are the two main things i do is
videos about games and choke slamming
people
for me
i kind of understood that i was
transgender but i didn't really have
that term yet when i was really really
young as soon as i started to notice
like there was differences between
boys and girls which was like happens
when you're like in kindergarten
preschool where you start to like really
start to be separated out by like
teachers and by parents and things like
that i started to like look at the girls
and be like oh
that's more kind of like what
fits me
but i didn't really know how to
articulate that but i i only knew that
like
to be that was
considered wrong in some way
i think right from the start of puberty
i knew something was there but i just
never really
um
even thought to try and comprehend what
it was i questioned it for years
um
just in ways i was unaware was
we're explicitly questioning gender i
was seven years old and i asked my mom
for christmas i said mom i want pokemon
crystal
and she said
okay and then she got it for me for
christmas and i opened it up and bada
bing there was pokemon crystal and it
was the re the reason i really really
wanted it because it was the first
pokemon game where you could actually
play as a girl
um i also like remember some times where
i would like
tease other people to like play tag with
me and if i lost tech this was in like
preschool whenever i
you know would play tag with other
people if i lost the tag game i would be
like oh i have to wear a girl's dress
immediately decided to pick a girl
because duh
and uh
like the first name i came up with was
may
and that's just stuck
and so of course i would lose the the
game repeatedly um and then i would have
to put on a dress in front of other
people
and i remember like i would put on the
dress in the bathroom and just like
really enjoy it but then step out into
the
the
you know the the classroom the the
daycare that i was in
and
you feel the sense of laughter
and
there there became this sort of
understanding
that
the person that i wanted to be
was laughable like there are
moments now looking back
um where there were clues that go back
as far as like six years old
possibly before i don't know but that's
the first time i really remember
being confused for a girl because we
were too poor to have haircuts
um so i had a lot fairly long hair and
got confused um for a girl once and
really liked it like it
felt
correct
but i
i just buried it i didn't want to be
seen as laughable and so i tried to
double down on being masculine and tried
to be super super masculine so when i
went to college
i i really tried to be that way but it
didn't really
work for me i watched a coming out video
in 2019
and realized that the trans person
coming out who was uh hannah reloaded
i'll give her
a shout-out i guess
watching her come out um and realizing
that she was just describing
a lot of my feelings
uh just sort of uh kicked me into
realizing what was going on
but for me it's come from a belief that
there was a lot of physical
um
gender crossing already there i used to
talk about having a hormonal imbalance
because that was the only way i could
describe the
physical femme features i already had
and
over time realized it wasn't an
imbalance or certainly not
in the them direction uh it was just
a need to
polish what was there uh reducing things
i didn't want i wasn't really the big
strong guy i was i was much more like
you know i was
compassionate i was open and that's not
a bad thing for a man to be but it was
just it was just it always felt like i
was failing at being a man
and that started to depress me more and
more and more and more and more and more
especially in college where because i
wasn't at home anymore i couldn't like
wear women's clothing at any time i had
no outlet
to share myself in any way the the long
and sordid
bit of it is is being you know 17 and
realizing once again that you're trans
and then being 21 and once again
realizing that you're trans and then
being 24 and once again realizing that
you're trans but it wasn't until
last year
that i was able to start putting
um words to the feelings and
[Music]
felt bold enough to
transition i just got so incredibly
depressed
and there was this moment of like i
don't want to fulfill this function
anymore i don't want to play this role
of being a guy anymore and it was
one of the darkest times of my life
because i live in the deep south i live
in texas and because i was raised by a
mostly conservative family i didn't
really get a lot of opportunity to
explore that aspect of myself until i
was really out on my own
and then since then i've been
confident that i'm trans but also
vaguely confused
luckily
this was also the same time because i
was in college that was my first time to
meet people beyond my initial like i
grew up in a small like well the school
that i went to was a small rural school
and so this college was the first time
that i really got to meet like people
who are openly lgbtq
and i met two friends
who were so like openly bisexual openly
like talking about sex and all this
stuff and it was it was really helpful
for me
and
i just sort of was like if i don't tell
anybody i'm going to do something worse
and so i told them
once i got out on my own i began to feel
like this intense like
i guess
like regret for all that lost time but
i've come to change my mind about that
and i'm mostly just very very happy
that i'm here
i would talk to
a very dear friend of mine phoenix who
um was talking to me about clothing
choices at one point and when i do my
training
i would wear
women's
clothes because they were more
comfortable they fit me better and
i thought that was it
well no i didn't because part of me was
always um
[Music]
always enjoyed it and liked letting
people know i enjoyed it
um not in a
you know not in a sexy way just in a
comfort way this stuff fits me better
and part of me always wanted to express
that to people and let them know so i'm
more thankful to the brave soul that
once existed in my body that was able to
do that
um
then i am critical of that person
i i feel like that person saved my life
i told them that i was trans that i was
a girl
and i remember the night that i did that
i told one of them
for the first time and it was five
minutes of just like this deep
telling this deep secret
of like i am a girl
and they saw me and heard me
and then after that we just talked about
nerd [ __ ] after that it was the nicest
thing it was like oh i get to be
i'm still me they still see me and and
gender really is just a part of that but
it's still me
talking to fee
they said
you know what i i always picked up there
wasn't something quite cis about you
and that hit me like a brick
because i had ingrained into my head so
much that this is what i was and i
couldn't
change that
so that
switched a light on
and then it was
kind of a snowball effect
my coming out was not super
great uh my family
didn't appreciate it uh at all
um and
i yeah lost housing it was is a big pain
in the butt i generally tend to be an
open book anyway i don't like
i mean i don't really have many impulses
to keep things secret unless there are
other people's private stuff that i have
no right to be sharing as i say though
once the door was open the
it all just poured out and that's
you know
why i've so quickly embraced it
um over the course of this year
but the thing that i've always held on
to is like it's always just me
and this is just a piece of
a piece of who i am
at the at the end of the day i'm glad i
did it i'm glad that i figured out
how to stand on my own two feet and
that's kind of been my most valuable
asset going into the remainder of my
life
is just that ability to stand on my own
two feet and i feel like
had i not had it as hard as i did
coming up
you know i probably wouldn't be quite as
like independent as i am now
so i'm i'm somewhat thankful for my
upbringing but at the same time
it was uh
awful
so i i didn't really ever feel that
being trans was a secret but it did feel
like a big deal to share and it did take
me a while to
to say it out loud it was unplanned
it was
not something i was necessarily building
to i knew it would have to happen one
day um but i was planning
far later down the line
um i was like at least wait till i get
my new hat
which is finally on its way to me took a
year to get finished but it's a very
good time
but i couldn't wait that long the time
that i started talking about trans
issues on the channel and started
talking about transitions publicly
was
sort of two moments of my life one where
i was just in the sort of beginning
phases of transition like i've been out
for about a year or two but on hormones
for a year or two i had just had gender
confirmation surgery vaginoplasty and so
there was all this new information and
stuff that i was processing and learning
and trying to work through so i was like
oh gender is a social construct what
does that mean oh like what does it feel
like to have a new vagina at
you know 20 years old what it's like to
go through a new puberty at 20 years old
like this whole
like this whole slew of experiences
when i came out it was a very different
world um you know it was like right off
the the coattails of like gamergate and
stuff like that there was a big push
against trans people there's a big push
against like women's rights
leftism in general stuff like that i
think the main things holding me back
were
the idea that um
once i've said it i will always have
said it so in this time that i wasn't
really
sure uh and this time that i wasn't i
didn't really know what was going on and
i was still very confused i've been
softly building to it on places like
instagram where i show up a little more
um
and and before the video was published
it seemed like some transports had
worked out what was gonna happen
um
and started pre-abusing me
um pre-harassing it was still committing
to something even if i was committing to
just being public about being confused
which is why
it took me much longer than
you know it could have to come out but
what changed with
the video with coming out
was the night before i'd gone out for
the first time
fully presenting and it was the very
first time in my life that i felt like i
didn't need to apologize for existing
and being sane
i was terrified
to come out online because i knew for a
fact that
a lot of the audience really didn't want
that to be my future
like they wanted me to stay doing
exactly what i was doing and never ever
change it was the first time in my life
that i didn't mind
being noticed
and it was the first time in my life i
could actually just sit there you know
dining outside of course be responsible
um
[Music]
and i just didn't feel
afraid to be
i think a lot of people saw themselves
in me and they wanted me to remain
consistent so that they themselves
didn't have to change and feeling that
way the next morning when it came time
to film for the inquisition i couldn't
go back i just couldn't do it i couldn't
put on the
the man costume anymore i i sort of used
youtube to be this place to
articulate some of the things that i was
feeling to process them to put them out
in hopefully an educational way so we
just went ahead and did it and it was
scary uh it was
i had nerves contra points came out
like two months before this and she did
this big elaborate video
with all these theatrics about you know
why she was coming out how she felt and
what she was initially going to you know
be doing and so it kind of laid this
sort of road map for a lot of people
and i didn't want to do that and i spoke
to laura kate dale who said look that's
what they want they want you to feel too
afraid to come out but once you've done
it you've you've beaten them
i was so nervous about it that i just
quickly threw
an outfit together quickly threw all the
stuff together didn't even use like an
external microphone didn't didn't light
the video very well like i barely put
any effort into it at all
because i was so scared so i just hit
publish and then
and let the troops fall where they may
um but yeah it wasn't planned and i
didn't make a big deal out of it there
was no press blast there was no
dedicated video
um
and that feels on theme for me to just
to just be there and say hey
here i am
here's the thing i'm
doing here's
is me i've never made a coming out video
or anything i've just sort of
um
instead stopped hiding anything
while no one seemed to be expecting a
full fem
appearance
i
had come out as non-binary i
had mentioned in one
i think two videos um
last year that i was on hrt
and
was experimenting with the lipstick
it's three in the morning when it
published
it blew up immediately
and the video was called the truth
because i made a joke in the video where
i was like i'm now realizing that as a
youtuber i am withholding a big secret
and i could potentially use that for
financial gain
the lipstick wasn't so shocking to
people because
i've always been very
colorful in my presentation let's say
um i always wore an outfit costume
so that being part of it
wasn't that shocking as i was even
before i came out i think
every video
on my channel for a while included at
least one trans joke as in i am trans
joke
but um very few people noticed or cared
for the most part my approach was just
trying to be straightforward about it
and just trying to be like hey
here's my struggle
here's what i've been dealing with my
entire life
here's how i'm going to deal with it
and
like i understand that that might not be
something that you're cool with and if
it isn't
might might i suggest you find someone
else so like you know the film mulan
which is a you know trans icon film
there were just a lot of natural places
to make trans jokes in that video and i
think one of them made it into the final
edit
um
and very few people got what i was
referencing but i think some people did
anybody who ever has a public platform
or has some level of fame and then comes
out is going to deal with
um
those institutions like you know people
people who want to
write about and intellectualize your
choices
once i feel that i
have decided on my final name my final
pronouns and everything like that
um i do intend to make a video just
explaining to people what's going on and
i fully intend to call that video whoops
i trans to my gender
i thought that the struggle with youtube
was going to be i was going to get
harassed off the website but it turns
out
it wasn't that as much as it was people
supporting me
encouraging me not to be
like two leftist about it which is kind
of
absurd it wasn't until
until really all i did was add a wig to
it
um
and and that
yeah people took notice of that
so after coming out like yeah i blew up
online but that basically means that a
whole bunch of new people instead of
seeing new content from the new newly
out trans person just went back and
watched all of my prior stuff and
that scrutiny became kind of
overwhelming i've never been shy
about sharing photos of myself or images
of myself pre-transition i actually
don't mind sharing that sort of stuff i
frequently get comments on videos older
than the truth about how like
those were the before times you know
before i lost my mind and decided to
become this monster
uh
so it just got to a point where i was
like you know
every day that passes that i read
another thing like that or i see another
thing like that on something that's
older than where i'm at now it feels
like it feels like people clinging to a
non-committal existence like they're
clinging to something that isn't there
and i
have a duty i feel like to break them of
that spell
i totally understand other trans
people's sort of hesitance to be like oh
stuff before i transition that doesn't
feel like me it doesn't represent me at
this time it feels like a different life
uh it feels like there's this hard cut
off i totally get that totally makes
sense to me and then i just deleted all
my videos
uh and and i did delete them they are
gone
i mean there are some that i took down
that were mostly like
i used to when i was really young i used
to do like music video stuff it honestly
wasn't that difficult of a decision like
my first ever video on my channel is a
doctor who and rose shipping video if i
could turn back time that's the first
video i forget the name of the song
i don't care about anything that i've
ever made uh in my just generally in my
life i so i took down that stuff just
when i changed the direction of the
channel uh i am the kind of person where
i i treat art as kind of like
kind of like a bowel movement i know
that's crude i'm sorry that's crude but
it's true art is kind of a bowel
movement so you just kind of grab
something that you're feeling you know
you push it out there and then you're
like all right see you later bud and you
let it flush away if i want to be an
educator about transitions this isn't
the only way you can do that but for me
the way i like to do that is just to
humanize being trans because i feel like
in many ways many people don't see being
trans as is a normal part of the human
experience and i think being trans is
just as normal as any other part of the
human experience um and so i think part
of what we show that is just sort of
saying like hey look i i had a journey
through life just as like someone may
have a journey with their weight or with
their uh
you know with their job or or with their
cert any other thing in their life my
journey was with gender
and so
that's how you can relate in that way
the written responses were mostly
positive on social media people were um
excited for me um
very complementary mostly very positive
there were
the main the main kind of difficult
reaction that i found was the um
what a lot of people refer to as concern
trolls and i don't think that a lot of
them consider themselves to be trolls i
got a lot of questions
especially once it was a few weeks in
and people realized that i was not
changing back you know people's people
want to assume that you're not taking
good care of yourself and then tell you
to
and either their ideas of what taking
care of yourself means uh flawed from my
perspective or the things i've already
done and i don't need you to tell me
that stephen someone on tumblr went but
you know wow so we've just got to accept
your like your word as best and i'm like
yes
yes you do sorry
i'm the main authority on this
that's how that works
day and date was when i started losing
uh subscribers on mats uh it was 2000
that day
and
every monday since has been
two to as we well let's say the other
way around one to two thousand i came
out and then you know the subject
the analytics were really good for about
a month and then
it tanked pretty hard i don't know why
they draw the line of me being happy and
they didn't pog [ __ ]
or any of the other grotesquerides that
i have
played over the years
i guess the reason that there was a
downturn was pretty much
settling in is very different than the
reaction of a surprise like if you're
surprised by something you're like wow i
want to know about this even if you
don't like it
but settling into something especially
change is really difficult
i don't mind it so much
that so many people are departing
because the audience that's been left is
so overwhelmingly queer or queer
inclusive
one of the most telling things to me was
the
first full audience wrestling show i did
after lockdown there was an entire
section i just called the sterling
section that were there to see me
and
i'm not sure if there was a cis person
among them but i've had a whole bunch of
those people come back now and say you
know i unsubscribed to you then because
you know your video hits you close to
home i wasn't ready for that information
like i was transgender but i couldn't
tell people and i didn't know how to
handle it you know there was like
jealousy elements or things like that so
there were all these like conflicting
elements at play
um
in in
both how well the video did and
how
kind of scattered the reaction was
i would get sort of two different
reactions i would get nerdy people
coming in and being like oh
i i love your nerd stuff i love your
take on star trek i love your takes on
you know these different properties or
whatever
and i i didn't know that you were trans
and i love that you sort of add that
perspective
i feel like i'm finding my people more
and more even as i'm losing
um
the capital g gamers
more and more
the second one at the time
was uh
more trans folks or more lgbtq folks
they were sort of more people being like
oh
i see you you're trans you're talking
about these issues but you're also a
nerd you're also a dork and that's how
i've always seen myself the
hardcore gamers the
stereotypical ones and there's a lot of
them
um
are notorious for being angry at the
slightest bit of inclusion
and that's been worn out among a large
chunk of my previous audience
um
and they are now departing and i am now
famous for attacking gamers that's the
new thing i'm i'm known for
um
i hate i hate all gamers now is is the
uh
the common belief more trans people have
found me because i think there's just a
circle of hmm this person is trans i'm
trans i'll have a look and that's as
deep as it goes
and then they arrive
i got a lot of questions about whether
this was a joke or serious
um part of that is because i've been
known in the past four outlandish
costumes and dressing up
this was not one of those times it was
not an outlandish costume change and it
was certainly not a junk
um
taking estrogen for a goof is quite a
level of commitment
but i like to typically try to frame
myself and think about myself as being
the trans person in the nerdy space
being like i'm a huge nerd i'm a huge
geek i'm a historic let's talk about
star trek let's talk about doctor who
let's talk about stargate let's talk
about whatever the hell star wars
and then let me add my
perspective as a trans person into it
when it's relevant or when i think it
has something interesting to say but
otherwise just sort of add my own add my
own thoughts into it right at the
beginning you're going to get a lot of
pay
uh
cool good for you
and then
you're slowly over the course of time
going to
steadily lose a lot of those people you
know there's also there's also of course
the occasional transphobic hate comment
which i get more on twitter than on
youtube whenever i've talked about trans
issues on my channel they always got the
most dislikes the most pushback the most
insults in comments there's always like
the turfs and the the transphobes who
are
you know they'll come back out and uh
say like oh you'll never be a woman oh
you'll never be a da da da da for the
most part i brush it off
it
um
get onto the skin a bit um
but for the most part
you know it's not too bad but i don't
like it but those are typically pretty
easy to ignore because they say the same
five things over and over and over and
over again repeatedly
and so it's sort of like all right
you got your stock phrases and and
that's about it uh there was one video
in particular of a game called i don't
really want to use the name but it was
teaseler gladiator
and the video i did on that was
massively disliked and to the point
where people were gloating about how it
was bombing
people were furious that i censored its
name in the headline absolutely furious
um and they were furious that i spoke up
about it the transphobic comments that
appear on my channel generally appear
more about like characters and stuff i'm
reviewing than they do about me because
i think people who are transphobic don't
really stick around for long enough to
realize that's what's going on with me
any time in a review where i'd mention
in one sentence in an entire review
something questionable about um
um trans presentation in the game
uh people would single it out and get
angry that i dare talk about it like i
don't you know blame anyone for for
looking at me a pre-transition person
and assuming man i don't think we're at
a place culturally where
we can call that unreasonable i think
that's how people are raised and i don't
really
i don't really want to get into that
discussion i guess um ever since coming
out i've been too angry too political
according to some people
a lot of people have said oh you
criticize capitalism too much now when
i've been explicitly calling out
capitalism in my work since 2019 and
implicitly calling it out before then
when they when they assume that and they
see that i'm wearing like nail polish or
whatever and they're like my men
shouldn't wear nail polish i don't
consider that kind of comment
transphobic so i wasn't really including
it i consider that more to just be a
different kind of stupid tips history i
think the world changed uh the world
changed more than i did i wanted to show
that i was fundamentally the same person
um
so i'm glad there was no real content
change
uh there's been a perception change of
the content
i think that
i probably would have
been more successful had i not come out
and
the trajectory that i was on was was a
lot better than the trajectory that i'm
on now like financially subscriber-wise
things like that
i've spoken to some fans who said they
think i'm different now
and after discussing it with them they
realized that it was just their
perception that it was
they saw me differently because i
expressed myself differently physically
the world that i was in back then
was definitely more of like a straight
cis-head guy world
and that's what people wanted but when
it comes to my work i'm expressing
myself the same way i always have i've
not changed i feel like the world now is
more open to rewarding me
for being myself
over lying to them i think people would
rather me be
who i am than who i was nowadays
whereas back then i think they probably
would have preferred me to stay the same
um i think it's important to show that
i've not changed that i am not too angry
or too political i'm just me
i think i made very much of the right
decision
um
by
just accepting that the world was
changing
and that that meant i needed to be more
honest with myself
i think maybe the only thing i'd have
changed would have been if i
knew where i would eventually land on
the subject
um in my coming out tweet
that i did
um which is always a good thing to
make a big life
announcement is to do a tweet i think it
was
a quintessentially me way to do it i
looked the first overtly public tweet
was just a big meme it was just
i screenshotted
several things that were very trans
these like four screenshots with the
caption hmm
i mentioned that i was happy with any
and all pronouns
which was cited many times as a reason
to not use they and them uh even after i
had done some you know uh introspection
and realized that i felt the most
comfortable with that and i certainly
wasn't comfortable with he and him
but people kept referring to that tweet
to still use he and him
so my coming out suite has actually been
deleted
because
i just don't want people to refer to it
some people innocently others just
looking for an excuse and that was that
was my first like
overt trans thing that i like said
yeah there's something going on here
honestly i think the only thing that i
would change would be just to be more
outspoken about it earlier
i'm glad that i just kept it casual
uh that i never made a big deal there
that i could just carry on
being me that was the first time i sort
of admitted that publicly
uh admit it isn't the right word
i don't think but you know you know what
i mean
the other thing too though that i will
say that just the general perspective
uh of being a trans person
has just colored a lot of
how i view everything nowadays and i
think a big aspect of bad analysis
is egoist analysis it's it's asking
yourself okay well who am i
in relation to this work
and what do i want this work to be so
that it lines up with who i am and not
necessarily like the truth of the world
you know i you just sort of accepted the
way that things are
the things that like oh
you know this is this is the way gender
is supposed to be this is the way that
you're supposed to have your life this
is the way that you know you know these
these media properties were made and are
supposed to be consumed and they've
always been this way
um this is the type of representation
the way representation should be
so transitioning for me was largely like
accepting the truth of the whole world
not just myself and because of that i
had to handle my work completely
differently being trans
you know now that you sort of are forced
to see the
structures of society for the
you know made-up things that they are
you start to understand that in all
things in media in
in your analysis of things and so i
think that there's been an interesting
perspective shift and so i look at it
obviously with more of a queer lens
nowadays but
like
i feel like i can i can see through a
lot of character psychology in my
analysis nowadays that i couldn't before
because i'm i'm more freed up to
see people's minds as these like
not necessarily like standing point
things but they're ever in flux and
they're ever changing
and you see people as like these
consciousnesses instead of just
a body
it's it's accepting that everybody is
kind of like you
and if you do that it's like this ultra
empathy that you feel i still love star
trek but i also understand star trek is
a thing made up of
you know mostly sister-in-straight white
dudes
and they had a certain perspective on
that and they succeeded in many ways
because they were
a lot of them were more empathetic than
most but they also failed in a lot of
ways and that sort of informed my
understanding of it and so it's like i
can still love this thing but i also i'm
more able to critique it than i think i
would have been had i not gone through
this journey uh journey as a trans
person
i look at work now
i'm
i'm a lot
keener at understanding like the people
that play and
why they're making their psychological
decisions
uh
over
like looking at things and asking them
well how similar is this to my life
i'm i'm more openly genuine conforming
on camera and i make more trans jokes i
think my work will remain largely the
same
i don't i don't know that it's really
changed much more than that because i'm
still the same person i have the same
beliefs
i don't know what the impact of my life
would have been had i not done exactly
everything that i did
in terms of coming out and things like
that
no i mean
i i think i i'm fairly pleased with the
way things have gone
i think the only
change people have noticed
that i certainly agree with is that i'm
just
happier and more energetic and and more
more than
than i have been in previous years
embrace adaptation embrace change
realize that you might be a different
person tomorrow than you are today
because i was miserable
in previous years
when my
videos were at the height of their
popularity i
wasn't there for it
don't do the thing that capitalism tells
you to do
do not just make the same thing over and
over and over don't be the same person
over and over and over
but now i i can't and wouldn't want to
hide
how happy i am with
who i am
and
there you go
i hope that people found this
insightful that was my goal with this
one
and of course i have to give
one more thanks to
stephanie
may
jay and jesse
for giving me their time
their honesty
and
being
open about these things it's not always
easy to talk about
but
they were very generous and i hope that
if you weren't familiar with some of
these creators that you'll check out
their work
because
i've been a fan of all three for a while
so whatever thoughts you might have
comments uh not personal attacks
i really shouldn't have to say that one
at this point
but go ahead and leave your thoughts
down in the comments section and we'll
talk about it
like share subscribe help me as well but
no pressure on that
what i really want you to remember
is
that you are beautiful
you are valid
and you are loved
you are the council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
i i just realized i never asked you if i
can curse i'm so sorry kurt curse away i
will probably bleep it
understand that but go ahead
that's fine with me you can bleep me um
anyway